that have always been fears the Chinese
could be drawn into this war now after a
meeting between their top Diplomat and
America's a warning from the U.S
Secretary of State that Beijing could be
on the verge of sending weapons to
Russia we were very concerned that China
is considering providing lethal support
to Russia and its aggression against
Ukraine and I made clear that that would
have serious consequences uh in our
relationship as well something that
President Biden has shared directly with
President XI on several occasions but
that's not the only way this war could
metastasize and spread in an exclusive
interview with Sky News kosovo's
president warned that Vladimir Putin is
actively trying to export conflict to
countries like hers I believe that what
he's trying to do is to divert the
attention of the West away from Ukraine
the way how he would be able to do that
is create other conflicts in Europe
whether we're talking about Moldova or
Georgia or the Western Balkans it would
go towards Russia's interests to make
sure that the the attention of the West
is kind of everywhere instead of just
focused on Ukraine which rightly is
right now as if On Cue in Moldova which
borders Ukraine pro-russian politicians
were rallying protesting supporters its
government believes Moscow is
deliberately trying to destabilize the
country
allies gathering in Munich like
estonia's prime minister say they are
concerned by what Russia is doing what
what is happening in Moldova of course
we're worried this is a Russian
influence trying to destabilize
different countries and and this is part
of the hybrid Warfare the conflict looms
large over this conference where
countries meet every year to try and
improve the world's security a year on
allies can commend themselves on holding
firm and withstanding Vladimir Putin's
efforts to divide them
but there are huge challenges too the
alliance is not arming Ukraine at the
speed that it requires there is the
threat of a huge Russian
counter-offensive and the ever-present
danger of this conflict widening and
sucking in other nations
a danger that only deepens the longer
this war goes on
Dominic wagorn Sky News in Munich